dr nash has been helping people all
across the valley
lose weight and achieve achieve their
health dreams today dr nash
and total transformation who is
sponsoring this segment share a few of
their success stories
dr nash welcome to the show and i love
when we do this we're to look at success
stories and we have
three success stories we have many
success stories to talk about but let's
start with one
and that's your success story 80 pounds
12 years ago you kept
off the weight you look beautiful what's
the secret how did you do it before that
12 years of keeping it off there was 25
years
of me battling it over 36 different
diets trying to figure out how to get my
body to just get to a normal weight and
hold it
and what i found out was the difference
was going after the damage underneath
that drives it
so a lot of times jc we're told that you
get fat first or you eat too much and
then you gain weight but what i found
out for a lot of people in our country
there's damage going on in the
background running silently
and that's one of the biggest drivers of
the weight problem let's talk about the
first person let's take a look at
april's success story watch this
when i first heard about dr nash i
thought that this was too good to be
true
then i started working the program and
my pants started falling off this was
the best investment i could have made in
myself
look at april 63 pounds i love that she
said she thought it was too good to be
true
april it is true tell me more about her
right so april came in with a classic
problem where
after menopause she started gaining
weight nothing was working and it was
all in that torso area
we found out that she had a hormone
problem she had an inflammation problem
she had a fatty liver problem so as a
result of going after that damage hiding
silently in the background
63 pounds off five dress sizes down from
a 22 to a 12
and she's holding the weight loss it's
amazing with dr nash i've lost 19 pounds
11 inches right here i'm tucking my
shirt in baby
you got to love frank and it's a big
thing frank is now tucking his shirt and
that's a big thing how did you do it
for guys right so a lot of times i get
asked do you deal with guys too or is it
just a woman's only program no i
absolutely deal with men
and men by far are really self-conscious
they want to wear those shirts tied up
against their body and they can't
because they're trying to disguise it so
most of that 19 pounds and 11 inches
came off of the midsection
now he's tucking in the shirt like he
wants to and he's doing great
i've been with dr nash for six months
i've lost 35 pounds
four dress sizes my blood pressure is
normal
i've never been happier i love this 35
pounds is amazing but the thing that
really stands out with randy is you
normalized her blood pressure
how did you do it by simply using
nutrition
like prescription medication so the
problem is a lot of times people are
coming to me not just because they want
to lose weight but they have damage too
and they're just being medicated for it
this way she lost 35 pounds she dropped
four dress sizes her blood pressure's
back to normal and she's off those meds
that's huge success and you always bring
a special each week dr nash what do you
have this week
i do so normally just to find out if
you've got this damage and have a talk
with me it's going to cost 97
to do that online evaluation but
whenever you see me on las vegas now
with jc it's
9.97 but i do only have ten spots the
best way to get them
is the website that we're flashing on
the screen if you call my office
there's a high likelihood they're gonna
try to charge you a hundred dollars so
make sure you go to the website
and secure your spot because that's
where the offer is located
a big thank you to total transformation
for sponsoring this segment and again
visit drnash.com eval for that special
offer we'll be right back